oui effectivement on n'est plus dans le
constat que dans les annonces bons
constats que nous connaissons surtout en
commission d'aménagement du territoire
puisque on s'occupe de près des
questions de déserts médicaux
super lucie problèmes qu'il ya dans les
hôpitaux
c'est vrai qu'on attendait des annonces
peut-être plus spectaculaires et les
gens sont déçus je crois qu'aujourd'hui
falloir prendre le taureau par les
cornes
puis chacun des des problèmes sévères
sur nos territoires en matière
désertification en a déjà parlé je crois
sur ce plateau même mais nous sommes à
l'aube d'un scandale sanitaire
moi je le répète souvent j'en ai parlé à
mon ambition
il ya certaines zones qui sont
complètement oublié maintenant des
territoires les ars ne font pas les bons
des analyses avec tout un tas d'indicés
qui ne correspondent pas grand chose la
réalité plus truc c'est que certains
patients aujourd'hui n'ont plus accès un
service de soins de proximité mettre
l'accent sur la prévention on en parlait
sur ce plateau là c'est quand même un
changement de méthode dans la proche
justement et la prévention oui
évidemment mais c'est quelque chose que
nous connaissons bien notamment des
spécialités comme la cancérologie on
connaît tous l'importance de la
prévention mais la prévention ne règlent
pas tous l'accès aux soins c'est autre
chose avec la prévention on aura
peut-être moins de malades on va
peut-être évité français qui renoncent
actuellement soit aussi peut-être
qu'elle présention vainqueur à casser
les conditions de trouver à condition de
trouver un médecin de ses dépenses
d'économies
ce n'est pas source d'économie
immédiatement la prévention elle a un
coût et suppose de mobiliser des
professionnels ça suppose effectivement
mais mais ces jeunes et 18 hommes c'est
pas quelque chose qu'on vient d'inventer
elles existent alors qu'ils qu'on
améliore la prévention très bien et puis
après derrière on aura quand même malgré
tout toujours des gens qui nécessiteront
des prises en charge et des soins
difficile et herat est là pour le coup
bas la prise de recharge héros c'est
très bien ensemble de choses et puis
c'est vrai que il faut travailler à ce
que les gens qui souffrent moi je suis
très étonné par exemple
faites comme a dit notre système de
santé et efficace et on peut en être
fier mais nous oui non mais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous n'en sommes plus très
fier et moi j'aurais aimé quand même que
dans son discours dominant paré d'or ya
de la solidarité parce que on est quand
même sur quelque chose qui parle de la
mutualisation et de la solidarité
et c'est quand même pas ce qui est l'axé
sur 1000 ont il a rappelé qu'il y avait
des actes inutiles de la
surmédicalisation il a pris l'exemple du
plan en matière de lutte contre le
tabagisme ça ça fait partie justement
des outils de prévention comme ça c'est
le médecine de fond nous sommes d'accord
avec avec la prévention il ya d'autres
pistes pardon alain d'autres pistes
comme l'oeuf la télémédecine m'a fait il
faudra toujours des médecins pour faire
de la prévention des médecins d'ailleurs
les écrans aujourd'hui nous manque pour
nous souhaiter que nous attendions du
président de la république s'est plaint
au milieu tourments un discours
généralistes absolument avec des idées
des propositions qui ont déjà été fait
par le passé quand on parle de
prévention on parle de prévention depuis
les années 80 sur les progressivement et
peut-être même depuis les années 40
puisque malgré tout la vaccination c'est
une prévention
les vaccinations obligatoires dans les
années 40 et puis est venue la
vaccination obligatoire mise en place
par un amusant c'est de la prévention la
lutte frontale âgisme contre
l'alcoolisme c'est de la prévention
il ya déjà eu la prévention qui a été
mise en place depuis longtemps ce que ce
que j'aurais souhaité mois dans le
discours du président est publique
c'est peut-être un discours généralistes
pour expliquer ce qu'est la solidarité
française à politique sociale etc mais
aussi six ados c'est naturel s'ils
s'adressaient quand même aux mutuelles
et par-delà et mutuelles à l'assurance
maladie et aux organismes
complémentaires et je dois vous rappeler
quand même que pour ce qui est du reste
à charge 0 c'est une excellente chose
c'est évident pour ceux qui n'ont pas
les moyens mais ça entraînera de toute
façon pas ce cas pas de contrôle du
parlement au sujet des augmentations de
cotisations pour tout le monde au niveau
des mutuelles
n'oublions pas que ces dernières années
les mutuelles vont augmenter leurs
cotisations à plus de 50% ce qui est
assez considérable par rapport aux
cotisations de sécurité sociale donc les
mutuelles et les organismes
complémentaires moi je fais un package
complet augmenteront de toute façon la
cotisation peut-être pas la première
année pour que ça ne se voit pas mais
dans la suivante
ce seront les engagements et la
conséquence est que les gens ne perdront
pas leur mutuelle mais parce que la
mutuelle bassir qu'en fait elle est
nourrie par le contribuable en fait six
ans que je joue vraiment parié que des
mutuelles les organismes complémentaires
les obsaar enveloppe le monde vous dit
les grandes gagnantes
oui actuellement mais déjà par le passé
j'allais justement je prends pas